[Musique]
un an déjà que grièche scaffa lancé son
fameux rabais selon l'âge à l'occasion
de ses 40 ans le 40e est terminé mais on
maintient le rappelle vous avez 74 ans
comme moi c'est 74 pour son drap est
resté minimum 40 % pour les plus jeunes
quand moi ça semble bien alléchant tout
ça mais avez vous remarqué ces petits
caractères qui apparaissent au bas de
l'écran
il vous faudra plus que des lunettes
pour les lire mais ils permettent de
voir pas mal plus clair pour avoir droit
au rabais il faut acheter une paire de
lunettes complètes donc vers les
montures
mais le rabais lui s'applique seulement
aux montures et pas toutes les montures
seulement celles qui ont été
sélectionnés pour savoir lesquels nous
avons contacté greiche scaff en fait ce
sont les montures de marques maison de
grêce skaff ça veut donc dire que si
vous choisissez des montures de marques
connues
vous n'avez pas droit au rabais et ce
quel que soit votre âge